Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
你好，我是玛丽安。在进入今天的话题之前，我想先向大家预告一件令人兴奋的事情。如果你曾想过如何创造属于自己的收入，而不是不断地用时间换金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我商业导师丽莎·约翰逊（Lisa Johnson）发起的“通往经常性收入挑战”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这项挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是立志成为心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是身处完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. episode. With Dr. Marianne Trent Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast.
这些原则都同样适用。此外，还有机会赢取由丽莎本人提供的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，还有机会赢取与我——玛丽安·特伦特博士（Dr. Marianne Trent）一对一的辅导机会。想了解更多吗？当然想。请前往我的Linktree页面“Dr. Marianne Trent”，查看我的社交媒体频道，或者直接给我发私信，我会为你提供所有详细信息。好了，让我们开始今天的节目吧。如果你正寻求成为一名心理学家，那么让这期节目成为你的指南。我是玛丽安·特伦特博士，欢迎收听《有抱负的心理学家》播客。
I am Dr. Marianne Trent and I'm a qualified clinical psychologist. So we are now at the start of interview season for clinical psychology anyway. As of the Friday just gone, which was the 17th of March, you should have heard by now if you are being offered an interview for this year's clinical psychology doctorate interviews. So fingers crossed you have. So as ever, there are our compassionate Q&A dates that we've got coming up. We've had the first one, which I'll admit was supposed to be on the 13th of March. And I'm very sorry to say that I forgot. It was just clean, overlooked in my diary. So I was settling down, watching some TV and someone from my membership messaged me to say, oh my god, tonight's session
我是玛丽安·特伦特博士，是一名合格的临床心理学家。无论如何，我们现在已经进入了临床心理学的面试季。截至上周五，也就是3月17日，如果你获得了今年临床心理学博士项目的面试机会，你应该已经收到通知了。希望你已经收到了。一如既往，我们即将迎来“同理心问答”环节。我们已经进行了第一次，我承认原定是在3月13日，我很抱歉地说我忘记了。这完全是我日程表上的疏忽。当时我正安顿下来看电视，会员群里有人给我发消息说，哦天哪，今晚的会员会议
in the membership was amazing, but I'm sorry that it meant that I missed a compassionate Q&A. And I was like, oh dear, oh wow, I forgot to do it. So I did it the next day instead, I did it on Tuesday the 14th of March and it was really well received. And if you didn't catch it, you can watch it on replay on my YouTube channel, Dr. Marianne Trent. If you can't see it right away, toggle to the bit that says live broadcasts and it will be in there. Or you can look on the playlist. It's definitely in there for the Q&A sessions. Okay so the second of the dates that we've got coming up is on Monday the 17th of April 2023 at 7.30pm. I will try to make sure I remind myself a bit better this time so that it definitely happens at that time. I'm very sorry if you were looking for it and you
太棒了，但很抱歉这意味着我错过了“同理心问答”。我当时心想，哦天哪，我竟然忘了。所以我改在第二天，也就是3月14日星期二进行了，反响非常好。如果你错过了，可以在我的YouTube频道“Dr. Marianne Trent”观看回放。如果没能立刻找到，请切换到“直播”标签页，里面会有。或者你也可以查看播放列表，问答环节肯定在里面。好的，我们接下来的第二个日期是2023年4月17日星期一晚上7点30分。我会尽量提醒自己，确保这次能准时进行。如果你当时在寻找它而
were inconvenienced in any way. And then the of the series is tuesday the 5th of may 2023 7 30 p.m so hope you'll find those really useful so if you would welcome some extra support at this time then do please consider coming on board to the aspiring psychologist membership because people have found it to be such a useful resource. It's honestly been a lovely thing to put together and see come to fruition so beautifully. So there's more information about that in the show notes, or you can go to my website, www. learning a little bit more about faith and culture. And something that you may or may not know much about is Islamic psychology. So I thought it would be really useful to speak to somebody who's based in a different country and to get a bit of an understanding about him.
造成了任何不便，我深表歉意。系列活动的下一个日期是2023年5月5日星期二晚上7点30分。希望这些对你真的有帮助。如果你此时需要额外的支持，请考虑加入“有抱负的心理学家”会员计划，因为大家发现这是一个非常有用的资源。能把这一切整合在一起并看到它如此完美地实现，真的是一件美好的事情。关于这方面的更多信息，请查看节目说明，或者访问我的网站……了解更多关于信仰和文化的知识。你可能了解也可能不了解的一点是伊斯兰心理学。所以我认为，与一位身处不同国家的人交流，并对他有所了解会非常有意义。
His name's Khalid. And yeah, what he's studying, how he's studying it and how faith and culture impact on him and what he's learning and what he's understanding. So I hope you'll find this to be a really useful episode. And I'll look forward to catching up with you on the other side. So I want to welcome along our guest today, Khaled, to the podcast. Hi Khaled. Hi, hi everyone. So I know people are probably, you know, getting bored of hearing me say it, but we did meet on LinkedIn, didn't we? Yes, like everyone else, for sure. I love LinkedIn. And we got chatting because you'd heard Alicia's podcast episode that I did with her, thinking about faith and values. That's right, isn't it? Yeah, exactly. Like, the first thing other than LinkedIn, it was also Alicia's podcast.
他的名字叫哈立德（Khaled）。是的，他在学习什么，如何学习，信仰和文化如何影响他，以及他正在学习和理解什么。希望你会觉得这是一期非常有用的节目。我期待着在节目后与你交流。那么，我想欢迎我们今天的嘉宾哈立德来到播客。你好，哈立德。你好，大家好。我知道大家可能已经听腻了，但我们确实是在领英（LinkedIn）上认识的，对吧？是的，肯定和大家一样。我喜欢领英。我们开始聊天是因为你听了我与艾丽西亚（Alicia）合作的播客，探讨了信仰和价值观。没错，是这样吧？是的，完全正确。除了领英，第一件事也是艾丽西亚的播客。
Like, I saw the episode on my LinkedIn, also LinkedIn again. And I was like, Oh, wow, this is really interesting. I'm gonna like listen to it. And I followed it like directly after I saw the episode on my LinkedIn also LinkedIn again and I was like oh wow this is really interesting I'm gonna like listen to it and I and I followed it like directly after I listened because I honestly wanted to listen to more and more from the podcast so I was really curious on that great thank you why did that podcast episode specifically resonate with you in the way it did do you think uh first of all like personally anyway i believe that uh faith is like generally disregarded as you know something that can uh improve or this or or worsen a person's mental state some people can be traumatized by by faith and then they have a worse mental state some people can be uh totally enhanced in terms of like you know what they
我在领英上看到了那期节目，又是领英。我当时想，哦哇，这真的很有趣。我要听听看。听完之后我立刻关注了，因为我真的想听更多关于这个播客的内容，所以我对此非常好奇。太棒了，谢谢。你认为为什么那期播客特别能引起你的共鸣？首先，个人而言，我认为信仰通常被忽视，被认为是可以改善或恶化一个人心理状态的东西。有些人可能会因为信仰而受到创伤，导致心理状态变差；有些人则可能在思想上得到完全的提升，比如焦虑减轻或抑郁减少。所以我当时想，哇，你们两人提出的问题和回答的信息量真的很大，而且是更多人真正需要的。谢谢，我刚才打了个喷嚏，谢谢。我听的时候打了个喷嚏……好的，我很高兴它能引起你的共鸣，也喜欢这种提问方式。我们现在交流时，你不在英国，所以我们不得不安排一个录制时间，既不让你在半夜起床，也不让我这样。你愿意在方便的时候告诉大家你现在身处世界的哪个角落吗？是的，我目前居住在阿联酋。
think or their anxiety lessons or something like that or the depression is lessened or or decreased so i was thinking okay wow like you know what what both of you were uh asking and replying with was just like really insightful information and like something that more people could honestly use thank you I just sneezed thank you I was listening as I sneezed um okay I'm really glad that resonated with you and that you like the style of questioning um and as we speak right now um you are not in the UK so we've had to kind of organize a time for recording that meant that you weren't up in the middle of the night and neither were I so do you want to tell people a little bit as you feel comfortable to where in the world you're speaking to us from yeah so I currently reside in the UAE
所以比特伦特博士的时间快四个小时。现在对她来说大约是11点30分到11点45分，而对我来说是下午3点45分。所以是的，只有四个小时的时差，谢天谢地，不算太多，也不算太少，所以我的日程安排完全没问题。太棒了，你有没有机会去卡塔尔看世界杯？你有办法去吗？是的，很多……我认识的一些大学同学确实去了，但不幸的是，我没有去。没去吗？是的，我只是在电视上看了几场比赛，但没有亲自去。酷。那么，为什么这期节目特别引起你的共鸣？我们知道你是一位有抱负的临床心理学家，
so it's four hours ahead of Dr Trent's time so right now it's about 11 30 11 45 for her and it's about 3 45 p.m for me right now so yeah just four hours difference not too not too much thankfully but not too little either so it's totally fine for my schedule anyway brilliant did you manage to get across to go and see any of the world cup in qatar were you able to get there yeah a lot uh some people i knew from university uh actually went there but no unfortunately i i didn't i didn't no not for you not for you yeah I saw like one or a few games just just from tv but not not actually going there so yeah cool so um why did this episode resonate with you particularly so we know you're an aspiring clinical psychologist
但你目前处于职业生涯的哪个阶段？我正在攻读学士学位，目前在预科年，预科之后还有三年。所以，严格来说，预科是心理学项目正式开始并增加难度和强度之前的头一年。所以我还有四年才能完成学士学位，之后是研究生学习。所以我确实是在大学一年级。太棒了。我了解到你在英国大学的海外校区学习，对吗？完全正确。我目前在伯明翰大学迪拜分校学习。伯明翰大学在……
but what stage of your career are you at at the moment so I'm in my bachelor's degree so I'm in my foundation year and I have three years to go after foundation year so fun so it's technically foundation year is the first year before the three years where the psychology program actually like starts and you know ramps up in difficulty and quantity uh so I have four years to go for bachelor's and then after that is the postgraduate studies. So I'm literally in my first year of university. Great and I understand that you are at a UK university but a foreign campus, is that right? Exactly, so I'm studying in the University of Birmingham to buy right now and University of Birmingham in of birmingham like in ed bachetan was around since
1900年就成立了，但我的大学才成立几年，更不用说这个新校区了。因为以前有一个旧校区，我甚至从未去过。但他们有一个大约两年前才开放的新校区，如果我没记错的话。那时他们开始开设与埃德巴斯顿（Edgbaston）校区相同的课程和内容，只是在中东，具体是在迪拜。这太神奇了，因为实际上人们从不同国家搬到英国，甚至在国际间流动时，最棘手的问题之一就是学历是否被认可，是否相同。但如果是相同的学历，你就不会遇到这些问题了。
1900 but uh my university has only been around for a couple of years now and like as let alone at this new campus because it used to be an old one which i never even visited but uh they have a new campus which opened only about two years ago if i'm not wrong uh and that was when they that was when you know they started hosting the same programs the same content as in the EdBadgeton campus but just in the Middle East in Dubai specifically. That's amazing because actually some of the the tricky bits about people moving from different countries to the UK or even internationally is whether the qualifications are recognized whether they're the same but if it's the same qualification then you get none of that so
那么，如果你的课程等同于英国的课程，你是否有可能有资格在英国心理学会（BPS）注册？是的，完全可以。据我所知，我可能会错，或者可能会有变化，我不确定。但至少到目前为止，据我所知，如果英国心理学会认可伯明翰的心理学学位，而且这是同一所大学，甚至模块都一样，我们在Canvas上也使用相同的系统，演示文稿也都在那里，一切都是一样的。如果埃德巴斯顿校区有BPS认证，那么据我所知，
presumably if your course is the equivalent to the British one you'd potentially be eligible for registration with the British Psychological Society is that right? Yeah exactly because as far as I'm aware anyway I could be wrong or maybe there could be changes I'm not sure but at least as of right now from how from how much i'm aware uh if the if the british psychological society approves of the birmingham psychology degree and like this is the same university it's the same even the same module even on canvas we also use canvas and the presentations are there literally everything is there that's the same uh if you know ed bachston has the bps accreditation then surely as far as i'm aware
伯明翰迪拜分校也应该有，或者至少我认为他们正在努力争取，也许一两年内可能会改变，我不百分之百确定。我认为目前他们还没有，但他们可能会在一年或两年内获得认证。我希望如此。太棒了。但你知道，即使你最终没有获得认证，拥有相同的培训、相同的经验、相同的技能，并且写在你的成绩单上，如果你将来想在国际上工作，那将真正为你的未来提供保障。所以，做得好，伯明翰迪拜分校，因为这听起来是个好主意。
birmingham to buy should have it as well or at least i think they're trying to get it maybe in one or two years it might change i'm not 100 sure i think i think as of right now they don't have it but they're like going to get it like get the accreditation in a year or two max i hope so brilliant brilliant but that you know even if you don't end up with the um the accreditation still having the you know the same training the same experience the same skills and you know on your transcript is if you do want to work internationally one day that's gonna you know it's gonna really future-proof you so well. So, yeah, well done to Birmingham Dubai campus, because that sounds like a great idea.
我想，归根结底，大学是企业，是赚钱的机构，不是吗？虽然人们常说“学术”、“我们在改善人们的生活”，但实际上底线是他们想赚钱，而他们赚钱的业务就是教育人们。所以如果他们看到市场上有缺口，他们就会利用它。但我认为这是一个相当精明的举动。我印象非常深刻。确实。如果我可以补充一点的话。
And I guess, you know, at the end of the day, universities are businesses and they're money-making endeavours, aren't they? And, you know, it's all about, oh, you know, academia, we're bettering people. But actually the bottom line is they want to make money and their business of making money is by educating people. And so if they can see there's a gap in the market, then they're going to exploit that. But I think that's a pretty savvy one. I'm pretty, pretty impressed with that. Exactly. If I may add something.
当然。伯明翰大学迪拜分校是第一所在中东地区设立的罗素集团（Russell Group）大学。我们之前有过其他英国大学，比如现在迪拜有赫瑞瓦特大学（Heriot-Watt）。但我们没有任何罗素集团大学。所以埃克塞特、利兹这些大学在迪拜、沙特阿拉伯、科威特、卡塔尔或中东其他任何地方都没有。但伯明翰决定在迪拜设立分校，那里是旅游业最热门的地方之一。我们将会有很多阿拉伯人加入我们的大学。所以这确实是一个聪明的财务举措。我必须诚实地说。我也这么认为。也许可以建立一个“有抱负的心理学家迪拜”项目。
Sure. University of Birmingham, the University of Birmingham Dubai is the first Russell Group university to be anywhere in the Middle East. We've had other universities from the UK before. We've had right now in Dubai, we have the Heriot-Watt, for example. But we don't have any Russell Group universities. So Exeter, Leeds, those aren't in Dubai or Saudi Arabia or Kuwait or Qatar or anywhere else in the Middle East. But Birmingham was like, okay, we'll put Birmingham Dubai in Dubai, where it's literally one of the most popular places for tourism and so on. And we're gonna have lots of Arabs to join our university. So it was honestly a smart financial move. Like, I gotta be honest. I think so. Might set up an aspiring psychologist to buy program.
是的，非常聪明，非常精明。那么，是什么让你想要追求心理学事业呢？是的，基本上，小时候我总是换工作，就梦想职业而言。我曾经想当面包师，后来又想当电影导演，甚至想当电子游戏创作者。我考虑过很多不同的事情。然后到了高中，快毕业的时候，我仍然不确定自己想做什么工作，想把什么作为职业，或者大学该选什么专业。老实说，我落后了很多。然后基本上有两个
Yeah, very smart, very savvy. Okay, so what led you to wanting to pursue a career in psychology? Yeah, so basically, as a kid, I used to always flip from job to job like in terms of like a dream career you know so i used to think oh i want to be a baker okay never mind i want to be a movie director i actually want to be a video game creator so like i thought of like so many different things right and uh then like high school hit like towards almost the end of high school uh and i was still not even sure what i wanted to do like as a job as a career what what you know what the major to go into university like none of that right honestly like i was so behind and then basically uh like it was basically kind of two
因素。第一个是我报名参加了AP心理学（大学先修课程心理学），这是我学校当时提供的。我选择了AP心理学。但问题是，这是一种自学的AP课程，所以我没有老师。我只是自己学习，学校提供了一些考试或巴伦（Barron's）书中的章节让我阅读，以确保我读了所有内容。但与此同时，他们也不是很认真，因为那是疫情之后，每个人在学校的努力程度都下降了。
factors but the first one was when i signed up for to do ap psychology the advanced placement psychology uh that my school was like offering you know they offered APs back then so I would so I chose to do AP psychology uh but the thing is also um what's it called it's a self-study AP so I didn't have a teacher right like I'm just studying by myself and what the school like offered me so maybe sometimes they'd offer exams or uh you know chapters of like the Barron's book to read you So they'd make sure, okay, you're reading everything. But they were also not that serious at the same time because it was post-COVID, and everybody was just lacking in terms of their efforts at school.
所以学校提供的支持各占一半。顺便提一下，大学先修课程（AP）是英国A-level课程的美国对应版本。所以它们基本是一回事。如果你去美国大学，通常他们可能会要求AP成绩；如果你去英国大学，他们可能会要求A-level成绩。所以这是一种等同关系。但基本上，AP心理学是第一件事。
So it was both half-half from what my school side was offering. And advanced placement, by the way, like a side note, it's the equivalent, the American equivalent to a British A-level. So they're basically kind of the same thing. If you're going to American universities, generally speaking, they might ask for APs. Obviously, if you're going to UK universities, they might ask for A-levels. So it's like sort of like an equivalent-ish. But basically, AP psychology, that was like a first thing.
它真的很有帮助，因为它为我提供了很多洞察力。我当时从巴伦书、普林斯顿书等很多来源学习，只是为了那一场考试。它确实让我了解了心理学到底是什么，它的不同类型，甚至我还从巴伦书中学习了一些自我防御机制。为了AP考试，我学到了无数宝贵的信息。即使过了两年，我仍然保留着我的AP书籍，因为我非常珍惜它。但除了AP之外的第二件事是
It really helped, to be totally because uh it like offered me so much insight into it i was studying from like the baron's book princeton book like lots of sources as well just for that one exam uh and it like it really like informed me of course of what psychology actually was and different types of it and uh different uh even some sometimes uh different uh self-defense mechanisms i learned from bar's and like for the AP for the advanced placement exam like a lot I learned countless like so much valuable info just from that from that uh from that advanced placement exam I still have like my books it's been two years and I still have my books from them from the AP because I I just like cherish it that much uh but a second thing other
我个人在心理健康方面的挣扎。这听起来可能有点多余，但我当时确实在挣扎，比如过度思考，或者身体焦虑（如果可以这么称呼的话）。随着时间的推移，特别是在两年前，我形成了更好的自我认知，养成了更好的习惯。我当时在想，我能做些什么？因为我知道周围的人也在心理或情感上受苦。所以我在想，如果我能把我为自己所做的事情——即使只是以生活教练的方式——用来帮助其他人，传播一些我从心理学中学到的知识，
than the AP was uh like my own personal like struggles with mental health like uh it sounds even redundant at this point but i like genuinely uh like back then you know i struggled with like overthinking or uh you know like you know having like sort of like body insecurities if you can call it that and like you know i and later on as time went on especially two years ago i you know i formed my better like perception myself better did better habits and i was wondering like what i could do because i knew people around me as well that suffered either mentally or emotionally or whatnot so i was wondering like okay what if i could uh attribute this uh what i've done for myself even if it's just a life coach way to help other people uh and like you know spread some goodness or knowledge i learned whether psychology
或者仅仅是从我自己的内省或经历中学到的东西，我能做些什么呢？心理学家确实能拯救人们的生命。我也想过如何从心理上帮助人们诊断疾病和预防自杀。我觉得这些对我来说会非常有成就感。所以，是AP课程和我个人的经历，以及周围人的经历，让我想要追求心理学。太棒了。谢谢你的分享，因为思考是什么把我们带入这个行业总是很有趣的。
or just from my own like introspection or experiences uh what could I do to like say it's not safe because eyes but even like sometimes because psychologists do say people's lives so uh I also thought about you know how do I help people mentally diagnosing disorders and preventing suicides like I thought that stuff was would be extremely fulfilling for me so it's both the advanced placement and my own personal experiences and experiences of people around me that maybe want to pursue psychology. Brilliant. Well, thank you for sharing that, because I think it's always interesting thinking about what brings us to the profession.
作为一名中东男性，你周围的人是如何看待、提及或处理心理健康的？是的，这完全取决于国家。老实说，我觉得阿联酋在邀请国际人士和员工方面要开放得多，这就是为什么伯明翰迪拜分校能存在，它显然来自另一个国家，但他们成功地在这里建立了整个大学，并开设了许多相同的课程。甚至显然有一些来自英国的员工在这里工作。所以这取决于国家。我觉得阿联酋做得非常好，在我看来，据我所知，他们拥有更多的心理学项目，并允许更多人教授心理学。但例如在我来自的国家——叙利亚，
And speaking as a Middle Eastern man, how is mental health handled or considered or referred to by people um you know around you yeah okay so uh it totally depends from country to country to be honest because i feel like the uae is much more open in terms of uh inviting international uh people and employees which obviously how birmingham dubai exists it's obviously from another country, but they managed to make the whole university here and lots of the same programs and everything. Even obviously some staff from England,
心理健康几乎不被讨论。很多人并不真正了解它。有些人可能会感觉非常糟糕，但他们只会将其归因于宗教，或者说“我没有朋友”、“没有活跃的社交生活”，或者他们只是有坏习惯。他们并不真正承认“也许是这个习惯或这个障碍导致了这种情况，我们应该尝试从那里解决”，或者“也许你需要这种药物”。在叙利亚，这并不常见。我个人认识一位叙利亚女性，因为我们经历了多年的内战。她的儿子有时会在半夜尖叫，
for example, are working here. So it depends from country to country. The UAE has been really good, I feel like in my personal opinion, from what I know anyway, at having more psychology programs and allowing more people to teach psychology but it but for example in a country like where i'm from i'm from syria
这简直是创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）。他会在半夜尖叫，因为他小时候听到过炸弹声。她告诉我，他们去看精神科医生，医生会给他开药，但长期来看并没有什么帮助。然后他会继续表现出同样的行为。所以这真的取决于国家。叙利亚的情况从心理学角度来看一直不太好。阿联酋的情况一直很好，我想……我当然不能确定，但我认为其他一些国家，比如沙特阿拉伯、
in syria like mental health is like barely discussed lots of people don't really like know about it some people might like feel really bad but maybe they'll just attribute to religion or so i have no friends or you know like no social no active social life or maybe they just like have bad habits or something they don't really like acknowledge like okay maybe it's this habit or it's this uh disorder that's causing this thing and you know we'll try to work from there or maybe it's this medication you need like Syria it's not really that common like I I know someone personally a woman personally from Syria uh because they we've been having us we we have had the civil war for years now. So her son actually would sometimes scream in the middle of the night,
埃及，在雇佣更多心理学家等方面做得更好，引进了更多来自国外的人在这些国家任教。但它仍然不像美国、德国或英国那样先进。当然，还要补充一点，如今中东地区的心理学观点和知识比15到20年前要好得多。那时人们几乎不知道心理学，更不用说提起了。但现在情况好多了，人们的意识正在提高。例如，生活教练正在提供帮助，即使他们不一定是心理学家。生活教练
literally post-traumatic stress disorder. He would literally scream in the middle of the night because he would hear bombs before as a really young kid. And then she told me they'd go to a psychiatrist and they'd give him medication, but it wouldn't really help out for the long term. And then he would just keep doing the same behavior so it really depends like syria the situation there has just not that been good from a psychology standpoint the uae it's been really good and i i think i i can't be sure of course but i think some other countries uh saudi arabia
确实会提出“心理健康是这样的”、“如何养成好习惯是那样的”。生活教练也在提供帮助。但我个人认识一些阿拉伯生活教练，我认识的人告诉我，“这个人真的很好，那个人也很好”。心理学正在进步，但还没有达到那个水平，不像美国、英国、奥地利等国家。是的，听起来我们西方的一些心理健康方法正在渗透进来。当然，随着英国大学在当地的存在，这可能会加速这一进程。是的，完全正确。
egypt uh they've been better like in terms of employing more psychologists and stuff like that, getting more people from abroad to teach in those countries. But it's still not as good or not as advanced as somewhere like America, Germany, the UK. And of course, another thing to add is that the psychology standpoint and knowledge is so much better nowadays in the middle east compared to like 20 years ago 15 years ago people would just barely even know of it let alone bring it up uh but like now it's becoming much better people are getting more aware life coaches for example are kind of helping it out even if it's not necessarily psychologists life coaches for
我甚至没什么可补充的，因为英国大学在这里，我觉得这也有很大帮助。我觉得即使是10年或15年前，如果我没记错的话，阿联酋连一个心理学学位都没有。所以现在它正在加速发展。是的，它确实在积蓄动力。好的，当你完成本科学位后，你对下一步有什么想法吗？这是一个很好的问题。我确实对临床心理学非常着迷，
example they do kind of bring up all mental health is this uh how to do good habits is that and you know life coaches are helping out uh as well but i know personally some are uh some arab life coaches from people i know that they've told me oh this guy's really good this one's really good but psychology it's improving but it's still not there yet you know not like america uk austria so on yeah so it sounds like some of our western approaches to mental health are sort of filtering through. And certainly with the UK universities being present on the soil, that might well speed that up a bit as well. Yeah, exactly. Exactly. Yeah.
诊断疾病并深入研究，这是社会工作者或心理健康咨询师可能不会做的事情。所以我想更深入地研究，解决更严重的创伤和更长期的心理问题。我曾经认为精神病学可能是一回事，但我发现它对我没有那么大的吸引力，因为我不想进行浅薄的会谈，只是开药。我想与客户建立良好的关系。当然，只能在会谈期间。据我所知，你不能在会谈期间或之后与客户社交，比如“哦，你去过那家餐厅吗？太棒了”。不，你只能在办公室里交谈。所以我个人很喜欢那样。而且，因为我是穆斯林，我学了不少关于伊斯兰心理学的知识，老实说，这对我来说也看起来非常有趣。信仰和心理学实际上是交织在一起的，信仰如何能加速或恶化一个人的心理健康。我觉得信仰通常不被讨论，无论是穆斯林还是其他信仰。人们可能在心理上受到创伤，或者有错误的认知，或者在信仰方面出了问题，而这可能正是没有被解决的问题，因为
I don't even have much to add because, you know, the UK having the universities here, I feel like it's also helping quite a bit. Like I think even 10 years ago or so, 15 years ago, the UAE didn't have one single psychology degree if I'm not mistaken so now now it's getting like it's accelerating yeah yes building its momentum for sure okay and once you've done your um your undergraduate degree have you got an idea about what you might do next uh that's such a good question so i'm really fascinated by clinical psychology for sure
据我所知，心理学并没有真正解决宗教等事物的影响。所以伊斯兰心理学将是一个非常值得深入研究的领域。所以要么是临床，要么是伊斯兰，尽管我一直更多地考虑临床，而且我对临床更熟悉。你能多告诉我们一些关于伊斯兰心理学的知识吗？好的，我本人不是伊斯兰心理学家，但本质上，如果我没记错的话，在伊斯兰教中，我们相信有四件事需要照顾。我代表我的穆斯林同胞发言。我们通常有四件事要照顾：心脏，也就是你的情绪，在阿拉伯语中是“Qalb”；身体，也就是你的生理自我；
uh diagnosing disorders and like really going in depth like something like a social uh social worker or a mental health counselor wouldn't possibly wouldn't do so i would want to like go more in depth and uh tackle more like serious trauma more long-term stuff uh i i kind of thought that psychiatry like is sort of the same thing but i thought it didn't really appeal to me as much because i don't want to have like shallow sessions and just give medication and i thought i wanted to like form like good relationships with clients of course only during the time of course you can't talk as far as i'm aware you can't talk with socialize with your clients during and after sessions you know like oh yeah uh did you go to
灵魂，也就是你的精神；还有思想，也就是你的心理。所以你有精神、情感、生理、心理这四个方面，它们交织在一起，使你成为一个好人，一个榜样。在这一生中，正如在伊斯兰教中，我们也相信有来世，无论是天堂还是地狱。所以我们相信，例如，如果我有很好的人际关系，有很好的精神健康——也许我一直在实践我的宗教，但我有糟糕的生理健康，我总是去看医生，我感到非常
this restaurant so nice like no you have to only talk in the office uh so i would like personally love doing that uh and also because like i'm i'm a muslim so i've been i learned quite a bit about islamic psychology and honestly it also seems like really interesting to me uh how like faith and psychology are actually intertwined and like what what how faith can either accelerate or worsen someone's mental health uh i feel like faith is just generally not discussed like muslim or otherwise how like maybe other people might just be uh mentally scarred or maybe they have wrong perceptions or maybe uh you know they might just have something wrong uh in terms of their faith and maybe that's what's like not being addressed because
疲惫，也许我是一个吸烟成瘾者，所以我没有香烟就无法感到放松。基本上，这并不构成一个完整的健康人类，因为生理部分总是从其他部分中剥离，并恶化了你在这一生的整体存在。所以你可能在运动或其他体育活动，或者与家人朋友的外出中表现更差。这就是为什么，例如，在伊斯兰心理学中，这四个方面通常都必须被考虑，不仅仅是生理、心理、情感，精神也很重要。显然，有时从伊斯兰学者的角度来看，也许你有这
generally from what I've learned psychology doesn't really address impacts that things like religion have so Islamic psychology would be like really interesting to delve into so it's either clinical or Islamic though I've always thought more about clinical and I'm more familiar with clinical so yeah. Could you tell us a bit more about Islamic psychology, if you can? Okay, so I'm not an Islamic psychologist myself, but essentially, if I'm not wrong, so basically in Islam, we believe that there's four things, like I speak for my Muslim also. We usually have four things to take care of. So we have the heart, which is basically your emotions, which means qalb in Arabic. Jased, or the body, so like, you know, your physical self,
三个方面，但精神方面没有达到标准，所以也许你需要更多的实践才能感到真正满足，从而获得良好的整体幸福感。这四个方面：精神、生理、心理、情感。太棒了，谢谢。这是一个非常有趣的想法。我想你可能以前听我在播客里说过，这就像是把你的鸭子排成一行，或者至少知道你试图驯服的是哪几只鸭子，对吧？当我们看马斯洛的需求层次理论时，如果你的健康受损，那将真正影响你向上攀登金字塔的能力，而且它们是相互关联的。所以我真的很喜欢对这四个领域的明确关注。
ruh, which is your spirit, so like, you know, spiritually, and also, so the heart, the soul, and the mind, so mentally, so you basically have spiritual, emotional, physical, mental, so you have these four aspects are intertwined to make like a good, you know, being a good being and a role model. And so what I would do in this life, and as in Islam, we also believe that there's a next life, either heaven or hell. So that we believe, so for example, if I'm if I have really good relationships, and I have, and I have a good spiritual health, so maybe I'm practicing my religion all the time, but I have a good spiritual health so maybe I'm practicing my religion all the time but I have horrible physical so I'm always going to doctors and I have you know I can go is getting really
我想有时当我们把一些鸭子排成一行，或者如果你有三个领域看起来相当不错、相当闪亮时，它确实会给你动力去思考：让我们看看我们能为第四个领域做些什么，让我们看看如何让它与我想要达到的其他领域保持一致，因为它可能正在阻碍我的目标，或者阻止我达到最佳状态。是的，完全正确。例如，你可能总是致力于你的人际关系，但你的心理健康可能很糟糕，因为你可能更倾向于讨好他人，或者你只是为了情感层面而不是心理层面去做或说一些你通常不会做的事情。这是另一回事，所以它们在伊斯兰心理学中都是相关的。临床心理学显然也是，但通常临床心理学家排除了精神层面，而伊斯兰心理学则同时考虑精神层面以及其他三个方面。所以是全部四个。太棒了，谢谢。我认为结合这两者是可以的。
tired and maybe I'm a smoking addict so you know I I can't feel relaxed without a cigarette so basically like these so basically this doesn't really constitute a full like human being in wellness because the physical part is always taking away from the other parts as well and it's worsening your overall like existence in this life so you know you might be worse off in sports or other physical activities or you know outings with family or friends so that's why for example all four of these like generally speaking in islamic psychology must be uh like must be considered not just physical mental emotional like this the the uh spiritual is also important so obviously maybe sometimes from an islamic scholar's point of view maybe you have these
我认为你成为一名伊斯兰临床心理学家是可以的。当然，当我们为英国国家医疗服务体系（NHS）工作时，我们不会使用信仰干预。但我认为完全可以谈论，比如“作为一名伊斯兰男性或穆斯林，或者无论你想如何介绍自己，据我所知，这是我信仰的教义，我们是这样理解的”。但你并不是说“你应该这样做，你应该那样做”。你是在为客户提供一种看待事物的新方式，看看是否能引起他们的共鸣。所以，我愿意在治疗中展现真实的自己。所以，我不会分享我的痛苦，
three aspects but the spiritual is is uh isn't uh up to par so maybe you're going to need to practice more in order to feel actually more fulfilled and then have a good like well-being overall all these four spiritual physical mental emotion great thank you that's really interesting as an idea um and i guess you might have heard me talk about on the podcast before it's like having your ducks in a row or at least knowing which ducks it is you're trying to tame isn't it you know and um you know yeah when we look at maslow's hierarchy you know if your health is impaired that's going to really impact on your ability to move up that pyramid and it's also interlinked so i really like that that explicit focus on those four areas um you know and i think sometimes when we when we've got some of our ducks in a row or
我不会分享所有这些深层的个人信息，但我会很乐意分享我是一个父亲，我有两个儿子，而且我结婚了。你可能从听播客中知道我父亲在2017年去世了。如果相关的话，我很乐意与客户分享这些基本信息，因为我认为这有助于你首先成为一个人，其次才是心理学家。因为它为你提供了一些背景，让你感觉更像一个真实的人，而不是某种机器人治疗师。所以随着你完成培训，你很可能会在工作中培养出将适量的自我融入到与人合作中的能力和信心，而不会让一切都围绕着你，因为这不应该完全关于我们。完全正确。有时我想，有些
if you've got three of those areas that are actually looking pretty pretty good pretty shiny it does then perhaps give you the impetus to think let's see what we can do about that fourth one let's see how we can to get that more in line with with the others where I want to be because it might be holding me back from my goals or stopping me from being as well as I can be yeah exactly so maybe for example uh you might you might uh always be devoted to your relationships, but then your mental health might be bad because maybe you might be more people-pleasing, or maybe you'll just do or say things that you normally wouldn't do just for the emotional aspect and not the mental one. know that's another that's another thing so they're all related in islamic psychology even clinical obviously but usually clinical psychologists exclude the spiritual so islamic psychology considers the spiritual as well as the other three not just spiritual and not just other three so it's all four brilliant thank you and i think it's okay to combine the two
治疗师会说，或者有时治疗师会做的一件事是，他们会分享自己的细节，以便客户能与他们产生共鸣，但不会到治疗师变成客户、角色互换的地步。不，治疗师有时可以说一两个细节，这样客户就能与他们产生联系，或者认为“好的，这是一个正常人的事情，以这种方式感受或发生这种事情是完全没问题的”。完全正确。实际上，如果你不想使用自我披露，一个很好的口头禅是：“我合作过的其他客户发现……”或者
i think it's okay for you to be an Islamic clinical psychologist. So, of course, certainly when we're working in the NHS, you know, we're not using faith interventions. But I think it's absolutely okay to talk about, you know, well, I understand as, you know, an Islamic male or Muslim or whatever you want to introduce yourself as, as I understand it, this is the learnings of my faith. This is how we understand it. But you're not saying you should do this, you should do that. You're offering clients in different way of looking at things to see if things resonate with them. So yeah, I am okay with bringing myself to therapy. So, you know, I'm not sharing my woes.
“很多人告诉我……”或者“我想知道你是否可以考虑伊斯兰教中告诉我们的关于这一点的想法”。但你并不是真的在说“这是我说的，这是我相信的”，你只是在介绍可能存在不同的观点。当然，在动力心理学和心理治疗中，你根本不会使用任何程度的自我披露。但这必须让你感到舒适和真实。所以我们不会分享超过我们感到舒适的范围。是的，完全同意。你不想让客户感到负担，有时分享你自己的额外细节可能会让你自己感到尴尬。所以引入一个外部来源，比如“这些治疗师
I'm not, you know, I'm not sharing all this deep personal information, but I will happily share that I'm a parent and I'm a parent of two boys, you know, and I'm married. And, you know, you might well know from listening to the podcast that my dad died in 2017. So I'm happy to share that basic information with clients if it's relevant, you know, because I think it helps you to be a human first and a psychologist second. And because it just offers you some context and makes you feel more like a tangible human rather than some robotic therapist, you know. So as you go through your training you might well develop some competence and confidence in just weaving in appropriate amounts of yourself into the work you do with people without it being all about you because it shouldn't be all about us exactly yeah like I sometimes think that I'm like okay maybe uh i've seen before that some
也认为你应该这样做”，等等。太棒了。那么，无论你最终追求什么角色，拥有相关的经验角色通常都非常有益。所以，你是否有计划在学位之外开始做一些临床相关的工作，或者你可能会考虑申请的角色？这可能感觉很遥远，我们谈论的是四年后的事情，但你是否有正在考虑或会考虑的角色？比如实习，对吧？在这个国家，我们可能有精神病院的辅助工作、家庭护理、助教或助理心理学家，有一个完整的心理学……
therapists say or uh that you know maybe something that uh therapists can sometimes do not always but sometimes do is uh they bring up their own details so that the that the client can resonate with them but not to the point where the therapist becomes like the client and they switch roles like no like uh the therapist can sometimes say some details one or two or something uh so that the client can like relate to them or think like okay this is a normal human being thing and and uh it's totally fine to feel this way or to have something that happened this way exactly and actually a good a good catchphrase to use um if you don't want to use self-disclosure is you know other clients i've worked with have found that
治疗师有时会提到他们自己的个人细节，以便让来访者产生共鸣，但绝不会到那种治疗师变得像来访者一样互换角色的程度。不，治疗师有时可以透露一两个细节，让来访者感到亲近，或者认为“好吧，这是一个正常人会有的经历”，从而觉得有这种感受或经历是完全正常的。其实，如果你不想进行自我披露，一个很好的话术是：“我曾接触过的其他来访者发现……”
or lots of people have told me that or you know I wonder if you might consider the ideas from Islam that tells us about this but you're not actually saying this is what I say this is what I believe you're just you know introducing that there might be different viewpoints so certainly in dynamic psychology and psychotherapy you wouldn't use any at any level of self-disclosure at all but it's got to feel comfortable to you um and authentic you know so we're not sharing more than we feel comfortable with really yeah exactly yeah i fully agree like you you wanted to want to just overbear on the client and sometimes you know bringing extra details from yourself might be embarrassing on your part so you know bringing like an external source oh this these therapists
或者“很多人曾告诉我……”，又或者“我想知道你是否可以考虑一下伊斯兰教中关于这方面的观点”。你并不是在说这是你的个人观点或信仰，你只是在引入可能存在的不同视角。当然，在动力心理学和心理治疗中，你可能根本不会进行任何程度的自我披露，但这必须让你感到舒适且真实。我们确实不应该分享超过我们舒适范围的内容。是的，完全同意，你不想给来访者造成负担，而且有时分享过多的个人细节可能会让你自己感到尴尬，所以引入外部来源，比如“这些治疗师……”
also think that you know you know you should do this thing and so on so forth. Great so you know in terms of whatever role you end up pursuing it's often really useful to have relevant experience roles so um have you got plans to start doing some sort of clinically relevant work on the side of your degree or you know roles that you might think about applying for it probably feels quite distant we're talking about you know four years time but um have you got roles you're considering or would consider uh like in terms of just internships you mean right and so in this country we might have support work in psychiatric hospitals or home care or teaching assistant or assistant psychologist um there's a whole you know psychological
“也认为你应该这样做”等等。太好了，所以无论你最终追求什么角色，拥有相关的实践经验通常都非常有益。那么，你是否有计划在攻读学位的同时从事一些临床相关的工作？或者你有没有考虑过申请什么职位？虽然这听起来可能还很遥远，毕竟我们谈论的是四年后的事情，但你是否有正在考虑或会考虑的职位？你是说实习之类的吗？在这个国家，我们可能有精神病院的支持工作、家庭护理、助教或助理心理学家等职位，这里有非常多心理学相关的机会。
well-being practitioners i don't know if that training has yet started coming to coming to the middle east but um there's a whole variety of relevant experience and i guess i wonder what the flavor of that kind of work is is looking like um at the moment yeah so uh basically like in the middle east like i've said unfortunately there's not as much experience as in the uk um even getting jobs sometimes i've heard even for for like because i live in the ue even getting jobs sometimes i've heard even for for like because i live in the uae of course so sometimes even for national students it's a bit hard like to always get a job on the spot sometimes you need connections or mutuals in order that you know can get you a job sometimes you really need like a qualification you really need the university
心理健康从业者，我不知道这种培训是否已经开始进入中东地区，但嗯，这里有各种各样的相关经验，我想知道目前这种工作的情况如何。是的，基本上在中东，正如我所说，不幸的是，这里的经验不如英国丰富。甚至有时找工作，我听说，因为我住在阿联酋，当然，有时即使是本国学生，想要立刻找到工作也有点困难。有时你需要人脉或熟人才能找到工作，有时你确实需要资格证书，你确实需要大学
degree in order for people to accept you so uh there's only i swear i think i've seen personally i think i've seen maybe only one person under 18 that's actually been able to find a job uh other than that though generally speaking like internships aren't that easy to find here uh maybe if the university offers you something directly like you know volunteering for example i don't know if it's volunteering considered uh like summer uh internship work in the UK like so honorary experience um is absolutely relevant but what can sometimes be tricky with honorary experience is that um sometimes it's fewer hours a week um because of course people need to be able to make a living. And so when we're looking at counting how many months or full time equivalent months people have had, it sometimes takes a lot of work
学位才能被录用。所以我发誓，我个人认为我看到的18岁以下能找到工作的人可能只有一个。除此之外，总的来说，这里的实习机会并不容易找到。也许如果大学直接为你提供一些机会，比如志愿服务，我不知道志愿服务是否被视为英国的暑期实习工作。所以，荣誉经验绝对是有意义的，但荣誉经验有时棘手的地方在于，嗯，有时每周的工作时间较少，因为人们当然需要能够维持生计。因此，当我们计算人们拥有多少个月或全职等效月数时，有时需要做很多工作
to even, you know, add up to a couple of months. And so that's why it can be deemed as less favourable, because unless you're working full-time every day for free you know five days a week which many people can't and shouldn't have to afford to do then it's tricky to to get the same amount of experience if that makes sense so um you know it's very much useful so i did an honorary assistant post and i did that by taking a day a week of annual leave from my paid role over 10 weeks, so 10 days. But whilst on paper, that didn't look like that's not even a month, you know, but actually in terms of my life, that was, you know, three-ish months, maybe even going on for four, depending on how spaced out it was. But in terms of my understanding about psychology and my confidence in talking about psychology and psychology terms and, you know, having a reference to put on my form that was a clinical psychologist and, you know, just my confidence in talking about all of that stuff and feeling like I could talk the talk and walk the walk. So in terms of what I got
才能加起来达到几个月。这就是为什么它可能被认为不太有利，因为除非你每天全职免费工作，你知道每周五天，而许多人负担不起也不应该负担得起，否则很难获得同样多的经验。如果这说得通的话，嗯，你知道，这非常有意义。所以我做了一个荣誉助理职位，我通过从我的带薪职位中每周请一天年假，持续了10周，也就是10天。虽然在纸面上，这看起来甚至不到一个月，你知道，但实际上就我的生活而言，那是，你知道，三个月左右，甚至可能持续四个月，取决于它分散的程度。但在我对心理学的理解，以及我谈论心理学和心理学术语的自信，以及，你知道，在我的表格上有一个临床心理学家的推荐人，以及，你知道，仅仅是我谈论所有这些事情的自信，感觉我能言行一致。所以就我所得到的而言
from those 10 days, I would say it was massive but on paper it looked like less than a month's experience so we don't always do it for for how many months on our form it looks like we do it for the massive leaps and bounds and it helps bring on our development so um you know I couldn't at that time afford to not be working but I could I decided I could take the hit of having two weeks less annual leave um that year um so you know still a little bit more rubbish because for the rest of the year I had less annual leave but actually being in that role really energized me anyway I loved I loved doing that and so I felt like it was worth it wait so you worked for 10 days over a span of almost four months and but you still say that like even though it might have
从那10天里，我会说这是巨大的，但在纸面上它看起来不到一个月的经验。所以我们并不总是为了表格上看起来有多少个月而做，我们是为了它带来的巨大飞跃和发展而做。所以，嗯，你知道，当时我负担不起不工作的代价，但我决定我可以承受那一年少两周带薪假的影响。所以，你知道，仍然有点糟糕，因为那一年剩下的时间里我的年假少了，但实际上身处那个角色确实让我充满活力。无论如何，我喜欢做那件事，所以我觉得这是值得的。等等，所以你在近四个月的时间里工作了10天，但你仍然说，即使它可能
been really exhausting or draining it still really helped you out even till now yeah so I was working for a local government I was like working for the council so I'd usually work Mondays to Fridays, nine to five. But I'd negotiated with my basically I knew of a clinical psychologist that was sort of working with some of my clients. And so I'd emailed her and said, is there any chance you'd consider taking me on in an honorary? I'll take some annual leave. and we wrangled a bit and then eventually she said yes um so yeah i then negotiated with my workspace to allow me to be essentially part-time for 10 weeks so that i could take every monday off to go and work um yeah under under a clinical psychologist so um yeah it's no more exhausting in terms of me doing days of work in a week.
真的很累人或消耗精力，它仍然对你到现在都有帮助。是的，我当时在为地方政府工作，我在为议会工作，所以我通常周一到周五，朝九晚五。但我与我基本上认识的一位临床心理学家进行了协商，她正在与我的一些客户合作。所以我给她发了电子邮件，问她是否会考虑让我做荣誉实习。我会请一些年假。我们争论了一会儿，最终她答应了。所以，是的，然后我与我的工作场所协商，允许我在10周内基本上兼职，这样我就可以每周一请假去工作，嗯，是的，在一位临床心理学家的指导下。所以，嗯，是的，就我一周内做的工作天数而言，这并不更累人。
But, of course, one of the key ways to not burn out as a human, let alone an aspiring psychologist, is to make sure that you take your annual leave. And, of course, that was two weeks worth of annual leave that I then wasn't able to take because I'd taken it doing honorary work. Does that make more sense? Ah yeah so you used up the two weeks of your annual leave during your internship during your work sorry so yeah and therefore you didn't have a holiday yeah it allowed me to not be at work so I was on annual leave um I wasn't getting paid by the honorary service but I was getting paid for my normal role so it didn't lead to any diminished income um for me okay okay I think I understand now yeah okay yeah yeah okay and in terms of you know I've just shared a little tip for reducing burnout is make sure you use your
但是，当然，作为一个人类，更不用说作为一个有抱负的心理学家，不精疲力竭的关键方法之一是确保你休年假。当然，那是我当时无法休的两周年假，因为我用它来做荣誉工作了。这更有意义吗？啊，是的，所以你在实习期间用完了两周的年假，在你的工作中，抱歉。所以，是的，因此你没有假期。是的，它让我不必去上班，所以我休了年假。我没有从荣誉服务中获得报酬，但我从我的正常角色中获得了报酬，所以这对我来说没有导致任何收入减少。好的，好的，我想我现在明白了。是的，好的，好的，好的。关于你知道的，我刚刚分享了一个减少倦怠的小贴士，就是确保你使用你的
annual leave have you got any tips to help you reduce burnout as an aspiring psychologist because you know when you look ahead it you know you said you said before we start recording it feels like you know 10 years time you know it might be like in a good place but at the moment it feels like it's like you know on the distant horizon so how are you reducing and avoiding burnout yeah it feels so close yet it's so far uh i think like i mean i only speak from a student and a student's experience but uh for me i feel like uh setting up a routine even if you don't always follow it like for me personally i feel like it's helped a lot so i don't like lose track of time uh and i don't you know waste or sit around and like not do something um i also feel like in terms to avoid burnout uh like just doing something like
年假。你有什么建议可以帮助你作为一个有抱负的心理学家减少倦怠吗？因为你知道，当你展望未来时，你知道你之前在录音前说，感觉好像，你知道，10年后，你知道，它可能在一个好的位置，但目前感觉它就像，你知道，在遥远的地平线上。所以你是如何减少和避免倦怠的？是的，感觉如此接近却又如此遥远。嗯，我想，我的意思是，我只能从一个学生和学生的经验出发，但对我来说，我觉得，嗯，建立一个常规，即使你不总是遵循它，对我个人来说，我觉得它帮助很大。所以我不会失去时间感，我也不会，你知道，浪费或坐着不动，不做某事。我也觉得，为了避免倦怠，嗯，就像做一些事情一样
in the middle like some people do pomodoro but personally i've never been able to do that exactly fix 25 and then 5 and 25 then 5 it's it's been hard for it's hard for me to do that but um just having some other system call it pomodoro have you heard of it i always saw it on youtube so it's it's basically this uh study or work technique some people a lot of people do or some people do where uh you study for 25 minutes you have a break for five you study for 25 you have a break for five then you study for 25 then you have a break for five again and then when you study for 25 minutes the fourth time then you have a 30 minute break so this is basically what some people do to study for like a full day or half a day or something so they study for 25 minutes then five minute break
在中间，有些人做番茄工作法，但我个人从来没有能够完全做到那样，固定的25分钟，然后5分钟，再25分钟，然后5分钟。对我来说很难做到这一点，但嗯，只是有其他系统。你听说过番茄工作法吗？我总是在YouTube上看到它。所以它基本上是这种学习或工作技巧，有些人，很多人做，或者有些人做，你学习25分钟，休息5分钟，你学习25分钟，休息5分钟，然后你学习25分钟，然后你再次休息5分钟，然后当你第四次学习25分钟时，你休息30分钟。所以这基本上就是有些人为了学习一整天或半天左右所做的事情。所以他们学习25分钟，然后休息5分钟
like three times in a row then when they study 25 minutes the fourth time they take a 30 minute break instead of a five minute so yeah but i personally was never able to do that yeah i used to do something similar with myself but with mars bars when i was to encourage me to to study i reward myself with Mars bars which yeah probably not advisable but um in short term bursts it worked for me oh yeah you know it's just getting candy like well what else could you want like something so simple that's so nice yeah Khalid thank you so much for coming along to the podcast and sharing your wisdom and your thoughts and the way you see the world um it's been a real pleasure it's my pleasure thank you so much for having me here
连续三次，然后当他们第四次学习25分钟时，他们休息30分钟而不是5分钟。所以，是的，但我个人从来没能做到这一点。是的，我过去常对自己做类似的事情，但用玛氏巧克力棒，当我为了鼓励自己学习时，我用玛氏巧克力棒奖励自己，这，是的，可能不值得推荐，但嗯，在短期爆发中，它对我有效。哦，是的，你知道，这只是得到糖果，就像，嗯，你还能想要什么？如此简单却如此美好。是的，哈立德，非常感谢你来到播客并分享你的智慧和你的想法以及你看待世界的方式。嗯，这真是一种荣幸。这是我的荣幸，非常感谢你邀请我来这里
you're welcome welcome back thanks for listening or watching depending on which you're doing i'd love to know what you think about this episode whether it's evoked anything for you and if it has please do come along on the aspiring psychologist community brackets free group um on facebook and i'd love to catch up with you there um do take a moment um if you are listening as a podcast or even if you're not um if you're watching on youtube still to leave me a rating and a review on apple podcast the aspiring psychologist podcast show that would be really appreciated please do bear in mind that the books the clinical psychologist collective and the aspiring psychologist collective can be useful for whatever stage you're at with your journey
不客气，欢迎回来。感谢收听或观看，取决于你在做什么。我很想知道你对这一集的看法，它是否引起了你的共鸣，如果是的话，请加入“有抱负的心理学家社区”（免费群组），在Facebook上，我很乐意在那里与你交流。嗯，请花点时间，如果你是作为播客收听，或者即使你不是，如果你在YouTube上观看，仍然请在Apple Podcast的“有抱负的心理学家播客”节目上给我评分和评论，那将非常感谢。请记住，书籍《临床心理学家集体》和《有抱负的心理学家集体》对于你旅程的任何阶段都可能有用
whether it is that you've got interviews or that you're still carving out your career and gaining your experience ready to apply to some other area of psychology or indeed clinical psychology in future people have said that they're really useful for helping them think about reflecting um and for also thinking about other opportunities and avenues for jobs so somebody contacted me recently so they're just starting a new role and they feel so excited and it was actually reading um those books that gave them the idea of that of even searching for that role so yeah good things happen and lives are changing because of this podcast which is wonderful the same can be said for people within the aspiring
无论你是已经有了面试，还是你仍在开创你的职业生涯并积累经验，准备申请心理学的其他领域，或者确实是未来的临床心理学。人们说它们对于帮助他们思考反思，以及思考其他工作机会和途径真的很有用。所以有人最近联系我，他们刚刚开始一个新角色，他们感到非常兴奋，实际上是阅读那些书给了他们寻找那个角色的想法。所以，是的，好事发生了，生活因为这个播客而改变，这太棒了。对于“有抱负的”内部的人来说也是如此
psychologist membership that feel like they got interviews this year because of the work that we've been doing to help coach them and to help supercharge their abilities and their confidence so do please consider coming on board if you think that would be useful for you and it's 30 pounds a month but with no minimum term so thank you so much for listening watching whatever it is you're doing i will look forward to catching up with you for our next episode, which will be available for you from Monday at 6am. Thanks for being part of my world and I'll see you very soon. Take care. With this podcast at your side, you'll be on your way to being qualified. It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast with Dr. Marianne Trent.
心理学家会员，他们觉得因为我们一直在做的工作，帮助他们辅导并帮助增强他们的能力和信心，他们今年得到了面试机会。所以，如果你认为这对你有用，请考虑加入，每月30英镑，但没有最低期限。所以非常感谢你的收听、观看，无论你在做什么。我期待着在下一集中与你交流，该集将于周一早上6点为你提供。感谢你成为我世界的一部分，我很快就会见到你。保重。有这个播客在身边，你将走上获得资格的道路。这是由玛丽安·特伦特博士主持的《有抱负的心理学家播客》。
My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological wellbeing practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me with confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself so if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay but trust me you will not put the book down once you start There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我的名字是贾娜，我是一名心理健康从业者实习生。我读了《临床心理学家集体》这本书。我发现关于所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的内容真的很有趣。有多少种不同的途径可以达到目标让我感到惊讶，而且没有完美的成为临床心理学家的方法，这让我充满了信心，不，我没有做错，并减轻了对自己的压力。所以如果你对成为临床心理学家感到有点不安，我绝对推荐这本书，只是为了让你安心，一切都会好起来的。但相信我，一旦你开始，你就不会放下这本书。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。